question to you guys do you normally
have like a normal like what's yours
what's your christmas day like what's
your typical christmas day
like do you have any schedules do you
have any like
used uh used to have uh you know you'd
open presents first thing which is
always the best part
pretty much goes downhill from there
exactly
yeah do you remember the age where you
just couldn't sleep before christmas
and then as a teenager you're just like
dude like i've
well i don't care about this you know
you realize uh when you were like i
don't know
did you always use to pick a lot of
things and you would get some of them or
did you get everything that you picked
i would get some of them because my
parents would also be like listen connor
santa's got a budget and i was like
really
so then i had to like look for the
product within the budget
right right and then i never connected
the dots
you know from age like eight or whatever
but i would i would go through like we
had a thing called like argos
yeah argos what's that it's like a
they had like a giant like [ __ ]
gigantic booklet
imagine the most depressing store you
can think of you go you go into this
store right yeah
and it's not a store it's just a store
of catalogs
so imagine like amazon imagine if amazon
imagine the amazon warehouse but it
would have like an amazon irl yeah
yeah you'd go and you could book it
online or back then you had to go to the
store and like take off the boxes you
wanted
yeah according to like the catalogue
that's depressing yeah it was but you
know
because the cats as a kid though this
[ __ ] was magical
because it had like everything in it
yeah right so you would go through and
and you know an adult now you realize
this was just [ __ ] overpriced
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know back
then there was no amazon so you're like
fitting it in the budget
yeah because how you go through is
because back back in the day you didn't
have like
you didn't really have the internet so
you'd have to order off this catalog so
you're going to this
arg or store and there was this catalog
that was like as thick as a brick you
could [ __ ] murder someone with this
with this catalog right it's like a
phone ball you'd go in and you'd flip to
like the index
so you just
[Music]
[Applause]
and so you flip through the index and go
through like the game sections and the
toy sections
which was like which which was the only
sections you really looked at right
um and then you it was just like free
pickings basically i know i never had
anything and then basically like
you know when i turned up christmas
morning there would be a few surprises
but most of the stuff that i wanted
would be there
except that one time like i said in the
cow said [ __ ] dad bought me
qriket tickets clearly
clearly expressed my disdain for cricket
but i thought you thought this is going
to change
genuinely like other than the gameboy
advance i genuinely don't remember what
else i got as a as
from like from santa one christmas i
just got like all yu-gi-oh
like i got the [ __ ] jewel arm thing
and i got like oh you got one of those
yeah yeah i got one
all my friends have got one as well
jealous we would turn up to school and
we would play yukio but then they just
stopped playing after they
realized i guess santa didn't have the
budget for that for me
i feel like i asked for one year but i
just didn't get it i mean feel like i
was like [ __ ] this look she doesn't need
that yeah it's like i think he just got
me like a bunch of booster packs
the graveyard and the fold-out thing the
back of the booster pack
yeah he'll be all right i remember for
me it was always video games i never
asked for anything but video games and
that was because
as a kid there were only two times in
the year when i could get new video
games
right and one of them was my birthday
and the other one was christmas yeah it
was a [ __ ]
rare occasion if i managed to get a game
after my birthday or christmas yeah
exactly
yeah so i remember it was like the
highlight of my year because i'd be like
finally i can play something other than
super mario 64 for like this
like millionth time and so i but i
couldn't get every game so i
know i normally get like two if if it
was like a [ __ ] special yeah
yeah it was like i knew my parents love
me when i got three videos
yeah three games was like the limit for
me yeah yeah yeah it's like 100 100 quid
120 pounds
yeah yeah yeah you're pushing it yeah so
i mean that's that's probably why i will
always remember the n64
because the n64 was just like huge like
god mode yeah
like i had never gotten a bigger present
in my life at that moment yeah now that
you say that i think i remember why i
wanted to
like why i kept doing like chess stuff
and being good at things
because my parents buy me [ __ ] if i
wanted things they would buy me stuff
sorry
i should just win the stuff that i'm
good at and they'll keep buying me
things
because whenever i like win a tournament
or whatever they'd go and buy me a game
and i'm like stonks let's just let's
just get good at something
i think that was me but just with like
school and like especially like japanese
for me like if i if i did well in like
my japanese tests and why not my mum
would be like yes that is my brother was
always better so it didn't matter i was
like
i gotta find another niche oh fair
enough fair enough do you have any
family traditions at christmas
we just have like family come over and
you know we have we have like two
parties we have like
one like christmas eve so like 24th of
the night we would have kind of bring
all of our like family friends over yeah
so like all my like uh
childhood friends and one on like friend
like friends from school and wanting to
come
to owls and then christmas day the next
day is when it's like family
like during the day for me it's the uh
for me it's the other way around like
family day is like uh it's it's like
it's like completely sober it's it's
like christmas day
boxing day is when the [ __ ] party is
at where we get like drunk with the
family
now boxing day's recovery day for us
boxing days like we've had two parties
back to back we've got to recover
i should have like family come over i
think and just uh have a nice little
little get together
yeah it's nice for us as well because at
my parents place we have like this
because it's during the summer in
australia we have like this big
we have like at our place with this like
big backyard like deck
that looks over right uh everything and
so like just crack open a cold beer
in like the [ __ ] 30 degree summer on
a christmas it's [ __ ]
i keep forgetting that that's weird to
me yeah oh we go to my uncle's place and
we jump in his pool and we're just in
the pool
all day on a christmas day it was it was
super weird for me like two three years
ago when i was living in thailand and we
were celebrating christmas in thailand
yeah and it was just like yeah
30 degree heat and us opening crest
christmas presents under a christmas
tree
and i'm like this this isn't very
christmasy i'm sweating
this isn't your very christmas see i
have to put the ac on yeah
it's just no it's it's i mean okay have
you ever had a white christmas
yeah i've had it once i've had a warm so
my my family most of the time
uh prefer to like go on like vacation
for christmas
i think they're just they just love
going on vacation and there's something
they always used to do is like
we're not going to buy you stuff i'm
going to take you places
which i appreciate now i [ __ ] hated
it right i'm like i don't want to go to
[ __ ] france mom i [ __ ] hate france
everyone in france is a dick
can you just get me something new you
don't see family on christmas
so it depends on it's like i think every
other year it's really like so we would
sometimes go skiing or snowboarding
which sounds [ __ ] epic yeah yeah yeah
your family have the right idea man they
are big but
you know when i was a kid i'm like i
don't want to [ __ ] be away this is my
time off you're making me do work
because to me right skiing and
snowboarding my family was like a chore
when i was a kid
right because they're so [ __ ] slow
right like
i would have to like go on a ski thing
and i would just be like i would wait at
the time
come on peasants yeah i would wait at
the top and i'm like just go ahead i'll
be down
i'll i'll follow you and i would wait
five minutes on my phone and then when i
was like
it's been five minutes time to go like
full speed down and yeah like overtake
them yeah
and then i just wait and then you know
also when you're a kid and you don't
have money
i'm [ __ ] hungry as [ __ ] and in these
results because like we would go on like
packages
right so they were pretty cheap like
nothing else
i'm very grateful but they were like the
cheapest possible way that you could go
to like italy and ski
right right right which is fair enough i
i mean i applaud the effort
but when you had to eat out at these
places they like charge a lot for like
food and drinks oh
yeah so like we're getting one meal
between us all we're all gonna split it
and i'm like [ __ ] mom i'm
starving like i would i would nut for
more than one sixth of a pizza right
right right
please but going now as an adult i have
my own money i'm like i'll waste all my
money on the food though i don't give a
[ __ ] i want to be full
no because like these activities i i've
realized the reason we enjoy them so
much as an adult could you do with your
friends
yeah no no no not just that but because
we can get alcohol involved yeah
like you know what i mean like it's it's
just like going on trips and everything
it's just
just funner with a pint and uh it's like
oh no
i guess yeah because what do you do
after you have your fun activity you
just want to wind down
as a kid you have [ __ ] nothing to do
but as an adult you can just
get drunk with the boys and that's yeah
i enjoy spending more time with my
family now that i'm an adult than i did
when i was a kid yeah exactly yeah
because i've i've worked at i've had
three white christmases and all three of
them have been because i was working at
a ski resort in japan
it's actually having a white christmas
in australia no no no no
that's that's a different that's coming
that's a different type of white
christmas if you're
sure but yeah like the like i had the
the whitest christmases in like ski
resorts because it's just [ __ ] white
everywhere but like
the only difference between the
christmas night at a ski resort and
every other night is that
there's just more white people outside
really that's the only difference
because like
because what do you do at a ski resort
other than skiing and snowboarding
you get shit-faced yeah that's the only
sauna sauna's normally a good chance
yeah or like onsen right but like other
than that it's like the only other thing
if you if you wake up in the morning
you're like oh man my body's feeling a
bit sore i don't want to go skiing or
snowboarding
there's nothing to do during the day
other than to go to the one bar that's
open 24 7 and just get [ __ ] first
and also because like [ __ ] skiing and
snowboarding is so [ __ ] exhausting oh
yeah you're like all right that [ __ ]
pint is like amazing you haven't been
skiing
i've never been skiing or something i
mean like
the the reason i've never been is just
because i i mean i mean every every
holiday we went to thailand
yeah it's also one of those things where
i feel like i don't know why my family
just were like let's just go skiing for
the first time i feel like normally you
go with someone
who's been yeah so they can be like i'll
i'll help you out yeah i'll you know
also like you know like skiing lessons
skiing lessons yeah yeah yeah also
you know when i was growing up i wasn't
in the most privileged position where my
family could kind of afford that because
i i feel like
going skiing is like an expensive
holiday or it can be yeah it is
i mean because especially if you're in
the country that doesn't have like
resorts nearby exactly right